[Music]
now where did I put that race to me no
comeback oh this thing ha ha here we go
hmm says here you're a science teacher
not exactly but you have teaching
experience oh no I can't say that I do
not even like babysitting I would never
sit on a baby I'm getting a really good
vibe about you hold on let me see that
resume it says here that you were a
genius inventor man genius inventor and
then for the last few years you've been
in a very dark place and your title was
revenge seeker yeah that's basically
what I've been up to
but honestly kid smiles bright in my
heart and fill me with joy adjacent
feeling well you seem terrific
you're hired what
don't you fear there's a hero
he's still a work in progress
salad sandwich
we uh
[Music]
under
reading waistband
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
slip your fingers in that Ricky Bahl
dude
you drop the trousers on oh wow he is
super dumb there he goes in his - inky
[Music]
the bad guys boil themselves every time
they hear
[Music]
[Music]
and breathe
here let me help you're welcome
[Music]
[Music]
hang on psychics
this morning school sign is supposed to
read sewage plant field trips are today
so can either of you explain why it now
reads come see my hairy armpits I know
you two are responsible how how do you
know do you have any proof ever since
you've attended this elementary school
you've been responsible for one prank
after another
[Music]
[Music]
Wow that's a lot of pranks yeah when
it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope some of
those must have been really hard to pull
off and dangerous like that tiger oh
that tank it was crazy ah what's this
why it's the paperwork to separate you
two huh it's really incredible I could
actually see the end of your friendship
George do something put the pen down mr.
crup or will hypnotize you when I snap
my fingers you will obey our every
command
[Music]
come sidekick
we gotta stop him why why thank you the
vehicle person yeah who's robbing you'll
get him what is this
poor soul you're trapped in some sort of
invisible box like prison
what's that I can't hear you but I see
your tears
is it okay that I'm kind of loving this
yes enough but mostly yes fear not I
will set you free
Wow Oh what is wrong with you oh that's
better I can hear you down sorry sorry
we're so sorry okay listen let's not be
punching people though we could hold it
kick let me help
you're welcome Adam Wow he is super dumb
we have to turn him back into Krupp I
know look can we just take a moment to
acknowledge what's happening here please
I mean Captain Underpants is hanging out
of that tree house well a hero's work is
never done
now it is time to fly again no no no
where are my pants
oh no he's crumb again ah Rolo that's it
now we know it turns on back and forth
turns who what why am i soaking wet Hey
Rolo promised up yeah we probably should
best about doing this role uh-huh I am
Captain analyst where are you good hello
well hello whatever you're not ah
[Applause]
[Music]
what is happening right now I don't know
let's try and leave and see what happens
Wow
what's an expensive door mm-hmm from the
studio that brought you Shrek Kung Fu
Panda and Madagascar hi I'm Jorge beer
miss my best friend Harold Hutchins we
just make comics and try to make each
other laugh
and this old guy is mr. crup George he's
the worst principal in the world ever
since you've attended his school you've
been responsible for one prank
after another some of those must have
been really hard to pull off like that
tiger or that tank it was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you to place its SAP
miss Glasson we're going to annihilate
the friendship don't you do something
put the ping down mr. crup or will
hypnotize you when I snap my fingers you
will obey our every command
[Music]
Rollo honestly nothing no what happened
this summer come sidekick we gotta stop
him vehicle person oh yeah what's Robbie
you'll get him their greatest creation
Captain Underpants you can't actually
fly I take to the sky like an awesome
wow he is super dumb
he's now their biggest problem down
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon hiya
Claire I'm your new teacher not some
scary guy with a secret evil agenda guys
I totally got this yeah totally he's got
it
Kevin Hart Ed Helms Thomas Middleditch
Nick Kroll
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants pour so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this yes enough I will said
you breathe Oh
but mostly yet
[Music]
[Music]